we've had a lot of calls that came in a
lot of people hitting us up just seeing
what's going on what's up with me right
now
you know there's a there's not a ton to
say I've been doing you know I watched
the comedy gives back I watched as much
of that as I could if you got to see it
I think they raised like oh I want to
say like I don't even know how much they
finished raising but I can imagine is up
near probably $700,000 for comedians to
you know to you know people that are you
know in the comedy community that are
struggling and that are out of work and
so that was really beautiful then it was
a damn basket fire dude if you freaking
had a cousin made out of gasoline and
you [ __ ] fed him matches for his
birthday that's what this [ __ ] was it
was just audio difficulties this and
that it was like remember when you got
one of those shitty us those sprint
phones those next tiles or whatever but
you could only you could call people but
then you could just talk to also you
could talk to one person you could call
anybody you want it but then you be in
the middle of a call like yeah
everything's going good every and then
you're cut your cousin or somebody Fire
Department whoever the only other person
that had the walkie your girlfriend
Chuck we need some [ __ ] milk back up
and you've got honey out hold a whole oh
hold on buddy remember that thing that
nextel way make some [ __ ] milk Randall
you like aw oh [ __ ] oh hold on Damien Oh
must be lines must be crossed up and
then you slick sneak click over Psalms
am sorry I'll be right there
the other uh there's a long line no
[ __ ] line you're lying
oh sorry man I gotta go bro remember
that [ __ ] Nextel it [ __ ] was Brian
horns dude it looked like it looked like
you they had it colored because it
looked like you were gonna need to be
rescued
like anytime you get that bright-colored
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] a lot of real poor like
sale racks have like real colorful
bright [ __ ] like oh look at this don't
you want this hot orange and this [ __ ]
is hot orange like the hottest orange
you could get is $3 $3 and for 40 cents
for this 7xl and it's like a [ __ ]
v-neck v-neck in the front turtleneck in
the back you're like what
and it's hot hot orange bra and it's
always usually oh but it's only a black
dude could wear it let's be honest bra
only a black dude could wear it and they
look good in it man it'll be triple lime
that's the color you'll see on the thing
it'll be bright bright green the kind of
[ __ ] like you can't the guy like if you
drive past it on the interstate it's
obviously the definite manager of the
guy who is doing the construction it's
that it's like triple lime in its size
14 double medium bro and that [ __ ] got
two arms in the front it's got an arm
out the back for exhaust like heat
exhaust as [ __ ] is I don't know we're
talking about bright colors they got
bright colored [ __ ] and it's mostly it's
predominantly a lot of times for the
urban community let's be honest but
because they look good in it you know if
white people wear really bright colors
should it look like they need to be
rescued real talking look black people
wear something mode that's triple lime
Oh Ernie got that triple lime hitter on
Oh woah he must be getting married you
know oh he got that triple I'm [ __ ]
overcoat with that double vanilla
cumberbund bro oh he must be he must be
doing a wedding but if a white dude goes
with that bright [ __ ] they look it's
definitely rescue only you know that
[ __ ] let's rescue only evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watches one